maintenant vous parler il ya de plus en
plus de requins blancs dans le fleuve
saint-laurent pourquoi vont-ils vers le
marron va en parler derrière avec le
plongeur est également le photographe
mario si bonjour maillot c'est merci est
avec nous en direct des îles de la
madeleine ce qu'on se rend compte c'est
qu'un requin blanc qui est aperçu au
large des îles de la madeleine qui
s'appelle brunswick
expliquez-nous ce que font les requins
dans nos eaux actuellement premièrement
c'est certain que lui un endroit parce
qu'on le suit au niveau par par
satellite à des requins blancs dans le
golfe saint laurent y en a toujours eu
en moi depuis y descend sans dernier à
l'année par contre y vivent beaucoup
plus mettant au large et au large des
îles bennouna déjà en lui mettant au
large de l'île brillant du rocher aux
oiseaux etc comment il ya quand même
cette sorte de requins qui existe dans
lequel vit même qui monte un peu dans
les su adam parr fleuve saint-laurent et
c'est pas nouveau la sécheuse que un
moment paraît bien on a alerté les gens
justement qui en avait un qui était pas
tellement loin du lieu du rab romestant
neuros juillet dernier et la dernière
fête compte que je dirai où la pub pour
la dernière fois c'est le 11 à oudon
qu'il ya à peine une semaine encore
autour des îles donc entre grossistes et
l'isle briand
on voit d'ailleurs la carte actuellement
qu'est ce qui explique la présence si
c'est à dire que qu'est ce qui explique
les requins blancs voyage beaucoup
on parle que ça peut faire facilement
dix mille à 12000 km par année donc
c'est certain que autour des îles
vanille a beaucoup de choix donc le
phoque est ce que même une des
nourriture de base des requins et il y
en a de plus en plus de femmes autour
des cds c'est certain que il est dans
leur manche et donc il est bien autour
des îles de marc il est sûrement pas le
délit il est sûrement pas de sol ou si
par contre les requins sanou bip ans en
bande dans sa vie de façon individuelle
le soldat donc ça peut voyager des fois
avec eux mêmes étant en couple du mais
c'est très très rock qu'on va les voir
voyageurs est ce que c'est en rapport
avec les changements climatiques parce
qu'on le sait les eaux qui deviennent de
plus en plus chaud de ce que j'en
comprends les requins préfère l'eau
froide alors ce qu'on risque d'en avoir
toujours davantage dans nos zones oui sa
vie dans les eaux tempérées mais il y en
a beaucoup mais tant du côté de
cali de l'afrique du sud ou l'autre
quand même un peu jeté un peu plus
froide mais c'est certain qu'on va en
avoir de plus en plus un tout et après
de bouger faut bien comprendre
qu'aujourd'hui dans les océans il a plus
rien qui ne tient sûrement en place nous
les humains on marche avec des arts avec
des dates les boissons donc dans les
requins marche avec la température de
l'eau il ya aussi aujourd'hui que 1 10e
de 1 degré cet bouger des débords
poisson à gauche ou à droite
donc quand on parle de taxer à cette
habilité de 2 degrés sur tarn dans l'eau
ça marche pas comme ça c'est encore en
fait comme c'était encore plus nuisez
parce que juste la moindre chose sous la
tente et l'inter chance a bien changé
complètement les routes migratoires et
le déplacement on a vu cette année c'est
au niveau de la pêche au mans c'est un
record depuis les 165 dernier avanies
compassion mort mais c'est le moment
qu'ils viennent de plus de l'est des
états unis donc sur la côte est et tout
et après de se déplacer même qu'au
niveau des baleines droit c'est parce
que la nourriture en montée que ceux
vers le temps donc les vallées non
suivies aussi et on est dans un vraiment
un échange par anouk et et non et oui on
m'en a mois de plus en plus des requins
parlez nous du requin alors ses
habitudes son comportement est ce que ça
mange beaucoup avec un wii se mange
énormément
c'est ce que quand il ya des attaques
chez les humains ben c'est souvent c'est
expliqué c'est parce qu'il ya des
accidents on n'est pas intéressant pour
eux on n'a pas assez de gaz s'est
habitué de justement de manger une barre
mais tant qu'on me des phoques ou deux
tours du grand et beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus tôt et plus et puis leur
pourcentage par rapport aux humains les
attaques c'est rarissime et où ce n'est
pas sa nourriture préférée vous venez de
le dire également la wii si son nom
n'est vraiment pas sa nourriture va
préférer et c'est pas le requin blanc
mais c'est pas le requin qui attaquent
le plus dans le monde assez le requin td
le requin bouledogue le retrait vous
donc bientôt rentrer dans les rigueurs
donc en auto-stop du côté de l'afrique
il ya eu quand même plusieurs attaques
continues directement par le bouledogue
mais ici il ya toujours ce a toujours
était quand même présent faut toujours
se l'appliquent le plus gros requin
blanc au moment où il a été pris à l'île
du prince édouard à petit prix mis en
afrique du sud ni du côté de l'australie
donc ça veut dire que passé pas loin des
personnes noires des
îles-de-la-madeleine donc c'est certain
que l'on sait qu'ils en ont ils évolué
par contre on les voit pas sur le banc
sur le bar de la plage quand elle dort
il ya jamais eu rama j'essaierai de
recensement à moins d'un demi kilomètre
de la plage donc où les gens se baignent
et je suis à peu près persuadé que même
s'il viendrait caf avant tout je pense
pas qu'elle a des attaques sur les uns
et sur les humains ya trop de choses qui
jeta très importante au budget
nourriture en suffisant justement à côté
de nous rapidement avec évidemment les
dents de la mer une psychose par rapport
à ça j'ai l'impression que ça atteint et
esprit l'ordi d'amérique sans rapport
aucun sens c'est en quatre ans parle
dans le monde des requins les
décortiquer premièrement le les requins
ne sont pas attirés par le sang humain
on peut arriver de l'on puisse couper un
doigt puis bas voire aucune aucun
intérêt il est ainsi attiré par le sang
des animaux où le taux de fer est
beaucoup plus haut et pour lui sur
l'idée de la nourriture le sang humain
et il n'y a rien du tout ne fonctionne
c'est devenu malheureusement un mal aimé
le lendemain des faits ou jazz d'un des
australiens des américains par an
derrière bord des bateaux pour tuer les
requins tellement on avait pavé
donc oui c'est extrêmement important à
600 ce qu'on appelle des super prédateur
donc complètement ou de la chaîne
alimentaire les certains scientifiques
de vis que demain matin mais des requins
disparaissent dans deux ans dans trois
ans des civils il ya plus rien dans les
océans lors c'est le chaos total
ouais donc c'est le prédateur et ça
pourrait aussi donc avoir un impact sur
les échos citant on disait aussi vous
avez un très beau c'est les yeux de la
mère points comme on peut voir les
magnifiques photos vous avez prises
mario cyr merci beaucoup d'avoir arrêté
avec nous ça me fait plaisir donc